attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
bien mon cher tom c'est l'heure de votre
bilan annuel c'est un projet de budget
absolument un peu comme au collège quand
vous étiez convoqué par le proviseur ah
non à l'école j'avais ce salon où
j'arrivais à faire beaucoup de conneries
sans jamais me faire chopper ici vous
n'aurez pas cette chance en tout cas
vous fait peur avec votre sourire
carnassier et vos yeux globuleux on
dirait un serial killer
sauf que moi j'ai jamais tué personne
enfin jamais d'humains une fois j'ai
tapé un sanguin 4 4 mais ça compte pas
bouger
cette année vous êtes arrivé quatre fois
en retard ah non non non beaucoup plus
mais comme j'ai toujours ma vie c'est
mon ordinateur allumé les les gens
pensent que je suis là à malin si ça que
j'aime chez vous sont vos idées
d'ailleurs je fais mes objectifs j'ai
droit à la prime force est de constater
que oui mais du coup pour l'année
prochaine je triple vos objectifs que
j'y arriverai pas ah bah oui c'est beau
ça je le fais c'est pas d'objectif a pas
de prime et avec ce que j'économise je
change de voiture en fin d'année j'ai
juste un petit coucou savoir s'il crache
pas sur ma gueule d'ange suis pas là non
pas encore mais ça va venir inquiètent
ok tu aller boire un café en attendant
au passage c'est moi qui ai gagné les
oies
alors j'aimerais profiter aussi de cet
entretien pour vous demander une
augmentation
un nom comme ça nous on n'a pas fait des
bénéfices records cette année
si si même et ça me fait chier qui se
cassent le cul la sucer les clients
c'est bibi 1 et entre les charges
l'urssaf et tout le tintouin
non mais mon vieux si vous voulez gagner
plus d'argent n'avait qu'à monter votre
propre boîte ok donc pas d'augmentation
quoi ça ça dépend voulez combien de plus
tu vas finir la négociation à 200 donc
je vais vous demander 400 en sachant que
vous avez divisé par deux bon alors je
préfère vous le dire tout de suite cher
tom le budget gelé mais je ne vais pas
vous donner de sens non sinon les autres
vont apprendre ils vont venir gratter ta
thune aussi je vais vous donner 35 euros
brut et un grand sourire d'accord allez
barrez vous maintenant il faut que
j'appelle ma maîtresse
[Musique]